el problema 3 sea r la región en el
primer cuadrante encerrada por las
gráficas fx igual a 8x cúbica y gtx
igual al seno de pi x como se muestra en
la figura a continuación la que tenemos
al lado derecho
inciso escribe la ecuación de la línea
tangente a la gráfica en x igual a un
medio
entonces como lo hacemos vamos a un
dibujo para ver qué es lo que estamos
haciendo tenemos aquí a mi función y
estás fx fx es igual a 8x cúbica esta
función de aquí yo lo que quiero es
encontrar la ecuación de la recta
tangente sobre mi función f en el punto
x igual a un medio entonces lo primero
que quiero hacer es sustituir a ver
cuánto vale el valor de f en un medio es
un medio al cubo que es un octavo por 8
es 1 entonces este punto es de un medio
1 que ya lo teníamos en la gráfica de la
derecha entonces solamente lo
corroboramos y yo lo que quiero es la
ecuación de la recta tangente en este
punto en el punto 1 medio 1 de mi
función
efe y si yo quiero una recta una
ecuación de una recta entonces que
necesito pues necesito un punto de una
pendiente entonces lo que necesitamos
sacar ahorita es la pendiente de esta
recta ahora bien para sacar la pendiente
de la recta tangente a un punto en una
función lo que necesito es la primera
derivada en el punto que quiero yo
encontrar la recta tangente esta va a
ser mi pendiente de mi recta
la primera derivada evaluada en un medio
por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo efe prima
de x 7 x es igual a 8 x kubica quien es
su primera derivada pues su primera
derivada es 24 x cuadrada y ahora si
esto lo evaluó en un medio me queda 24
por un medio al cuadrado primero al
cuadrado es un cuarto entonces es 24 por
un cuarto que esto es 6 la pendiente de
mi recta tangente en x igual a un medio
es 6 entonces m es igual a 6 ya tengo mi
pendiente y ahora sí sí ya tengo una
pendiente y ya tengo un punto ya puedo
encontrar la ecuación de mi recta que es
igual a la pendiente por x + b y es aquí
en mi ecuación ordenada al origen donde
yo voy a sustituir mi punto mi punto es
un medio 1 entonces voy a sustituir
cuando llegue vale 11 es igual a la
pendiente que vale 6 por x pero x en
este caso vale un medio ya esto le tengo
que sumar b y bueno esto vamos a
resolverlo cuánto vale el valor de veces
y tengo
números pues uno es igual a seis por un
medio que es tres más b y si yo paso el
3 del otro lado o si yo restó desde
ambos lados 3 me queda que menos 2 es
igual a b y por lo tanto ya tengo en la
ecuación de mi recta que es 6x menos 2 y
igual a 6x menos 2 es la respuesta del
inciso a por lo tanto vamos con el
inciso b encuentra el área de r
encuentra el área de la región r
la región r es la que está entre las dos
curvas que curvas pues está abajo de la
curva seno de px y arriba de la curva 8x
kubica entonces yo lo que quiero es la
región r por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo
entonces voy a tratar de bajar un poco
la pantalla para poderlo resolver
y bueno aquí para que se vea la gráfica
y yo lo que quiero si le insisto ve que
es el área y el área como se saca entre
dos curvas pues es la integral definida
de donde donde de cero hasta medio hasta
un medio que es mi valor donde se
encierra mi mi región hervé este valor
de aquí es un medio entonces la integral
de cero a un medio de la diferencia de
las funciones de la función que está
arriba que es seno de px que por cierto
océano de pie que hice de la función de
x entonces vamos escribirlo a la
integral de cero a un medio de la
función de arriba que era seno de x voy
a ponerlo aquí seno de px y bueno todo
esto todo en la integral va a ser de x
entonces le voy a poner aquí de x y
bueno hay que tener cuidado porque si yo
estoy sacando la integral de cero a un
medio de este no de px estoy sacando
toda esta área bajo mi curva seno de px
y yo lo que quiero es quitarle el área
que estoy dibujando de morado de color
lila menos hay que quitarle el área que
está abajo de la curva fx la curva de fx
era 8x cúbica y ya está lo único que hay
que hacer es evaluar esta integral
entonces vamos a hacer lo voy a dibujar
una línea aquí porque esto ya está
haciendo un lío bien y así va a ser más
ordenado
cuál es la integral de seno de px bueno
pues la integral del seno es el menos
coseno sin embargo yo tengo un pin que
me estorba yo tengo x
entonces para yo poder resolver este
integral lo que necesito es multiplicar
y dividir por pi entonces la integral de
seno de px es menos uno entre pi por el
coseno de pi x y si tú quieres saber por
qué me quedo menos uno entre picos en
nueve px vamos a intentar hacerlo con un
poco más de calma
entonces yo tengo el integral del seno
de px pero yo lo que necesito es la
derivada de lo de adentro es como la
regla de la cadena y la derivada de pi x
sspx y entonces lo que realmente estoy
haciendo es multiplicando por pi y
dividiendo todo por pi por qué
/ p es uno entonces el pis se va con el
seno de px y entonces al integrar el
seno me da al menos coseno pero yo tengo
uno entre pilla fuera entonces me queda
menos uno entre pri por coseno de pío x
que es integral del seno de px de hecho
si tú no me crees o en dado caso si tú
quieres hacerlo sería muy bueno que lo
hicieras a mano ahora bien también la
otra opción es que tú puedas derivar el
coseno de px si tú derivas menos uno
entre sí por coseno de px te va a dar ni
más menos que el seno de px y bueno a
esto hay que quitarle la integral de 8x
cúbica que es 2x cuarta la integral de x
cúbica es x cuarta entre cuatro pero por
ocho porque queda 28 entre 4 es 2 y me
quedan menos 2 x 4 y bueno también
puedes tú derivar menos 2 x 4 y vas a
ver que te va a quedar 8 x cúbica y
bueno todo esto evaluado en cero y en un
medio entonces primero vamos a hacerlo
en un medio si yo tengo en un medio me
queda
uno entre pi por el seno de medios
ahora tenemos cuando se cuestionen pri
medios menos dos por un medio a la
cuarta que es uno entre dieciséis y
bueno a esto hay que quitarle la
evaluación en cero entonces vamos a
hacerlo menos uno entre pi por consejo
de por cero entonces me va a quedar le
voy a escribir una vez menos uno entre
pi por el coseno de pi por cero y a esto
le voy a quitar menos dos por equis a la
cuarta pero bueno de hecho una vez vamos
escribirlo a menos dos por exceda cuarta
pero el valuado en cero me queda 0 y ok
vamos a simplificar un poco más esto yo
tengo menos 1 el triple por coste no de
primer dios pero cuesta 9 prime dioses
pero entonces 0 por lo que sea vámonos
esto no me sirve menos 2 por 1 entre 16
pues es lo mismo que menos un octavo ya
esto hay que quitarle menos 1 entre
people coseno de pi por 0 por 0 0
entonces coseno de 0 1 y eso me quedan
menos 1 entre p
-0 pues pues no no es necesario poner
nada y esto es igual a menos un octavo
más uno entre pin y de hecho podemos
simplificar lo tal vez un poquito más
sin embargo lo voy a dejar así ya tengo
ahora si la respuesta de inciso ven el
área que está entre las dos curvas el
área de la región
r es menos un octavo más uno entre pin
así que en el siguiente vídeo
resolveremos el inciso c